[Music]
[Applause]
daniel jeremiah i don't think they're
checking hand size for the analyst here
the nfl network analyst and former nfl
scout uh daniel have you had your hands
measured at the combine
i i've had my hand measured when i was
scouting because we would do scouting
clinics for young scouts at training
camp so when i was at the baltimore
ravens they had me measure my hand in
front of the group so they could teach
people how to measure your hands and i
don't know if i've gotten older or just
imagined it but i want to say i was
oh he was just ready to reveal and we
just lost content we saw three of the
fingers yes yes uh let's bring back
daniel so daniel what was your hand size
when you measured
yeah it was nine dan so it was right at
nine
threshold that was acceptable you know
you wouldn't know it watching me throw
the football but my hands were big
enough man this was a big deal with
kenny pickett's hand size and i don't
know how much it should be so as a
former scout if you were looking at
kenny pickett and let's say you're the
steelers what would this what would this
do for your opinion of kenny pickett
and where you were drafting based off
his hand size
well first of all you've you've seen him
throw a zillion passes in your exact
same environment so that that should
help you right there
when i see a measurement like that what
i think and i knew into the fall even
that he had small hands so
when you watch him you have that in mind
and i want to see is there evidence of
it affecting him as a thrower and i did
not see any evidence of that impacting
him as a thrower at the at the college
level um but then you look at the next
thing and say okay well what about
fumbles well he had 26 fumbles in 49
games which is a tremendous amount of
fumbles so that's where the issue is so
then you go back through and with the
video capabilities you have now i can
watch one fumble after another
and he's got a he's really got a bad
habit of separating his hands when he
moves around in the pocket so i i think
you can correct a lot of those issues
just by keeping his off hand on the ball
when he's climbing and moving around
inside the pocket so
those are reasons why i can i can get
past it i would have felt a lot better
if during the rainy day down there at
the senior bowl if he had a good
practice and didn't have a bad one but
that was his that wasn't not a good day
for him down there at the senior bowl on
that wet rainy day but
on the whole
i think most teams are going to be okay
all right we have a bet here
paulie uh says that uh a quarterback
will be taken in the first 13 picks the
over under was 13 and a half
where would you bet today will we have a
quarterback selected in the first 13
picks
oh i think i would i would lean towards
no and
but i i don't feel great about that i
would lean towards noah partly because
of ron rivera coming out and just kind
of showing his cards the other day
and saying we need a veteran so if you
scratch them off the list
that takes away one of those teams the
carolina panthers um we'll see what they
do in the veteran market um they seem
like they're pretty um interested in
trying to be aggressive during this
veteran period so i know one thing
whatever whatever the bet is i think
you're probably going to know after free
agency who's winning it
what do you think is going to happen in
free agency
i don't think the big guys are moving
you know i think aaron rodgers will
resign i don't think russell wilson is
going anywhere i think this kyler murray
thing will probably give us some drama
over the next month but they're not
treating him he's not going anywhere
so then then you start looking at
you know deshaun watson and that whole
situation and
waiting for the legal process to you
know to kind of clear up to see who's
going to be
you know who's going to be aggressive in
that in that way you know it's uh it's
unlike anything we've seen
with his situation i mean i think he's
26 years old um dan he's in the you know
he's absolutely in the prime of his
career and as a player he's he's a top
five player at the most important
position so that's a different scenario
than i've ever encountered
why don't we measure the hand size of
wide receivers or or make a big deal i
know they do measure but why don't we
make a big deal about the guys who
actually catch the ball
yeah no it's um
it's interesting absolutely you do we do
measure it and it gets discussed some in
the in the room but i think i've seen
some guys with with small hands have
some of the best hands in the nfl so it
hasn't been as much of an issue there i
think there has been some issues with
more fringy quarterbacks but
quarterbacks with smaller hands having
more of an issue of controlling the
football than guys with smaller hands
catching the football
but i mean deandre hopkins has i think
he might have 11 inch hands or something
he's got some of the biggest hand you've
ever seen he's probably got the best
hands in the nfl so yeah i think there's
a case to be made maybe maybe uh
uh maybe we should talk about it more
with whiteouts than we do with
quarterbacks but there has been evidence
of of quarterbacks of small hands having
issues controlling that bigger nfl ball
i just want to know how strong your
hands are
i mean i have grip strength yeah and and
that's with wide receivers it's like
jerry rice and chris carter you know
they didn't larry fitzgerald didn't have
good 40-yard dash times but they had
great hands strong hands that when they
caught it you weren't going to knock it
out and you know cooper copp like when
we talk about this 40-yard dash thing
and i i always tell my audience you got
to go back you know decades ago when
paul brown was looking for how fast you
ran down on a punt return
40-yard dash
we don't use the 40-yard dash in a game
it's very rare when you're running 40
yards it's and that's why these cone
drills
although i can't sit there and watch
them they're more important to me i
would think as a scout and you would
know this obviously better than me
that's going to give me a better
indication of can you run a route do you
do you have sharp cuts can you get in
and out of these routes how quick are
you in the first three to five yards
seven yards and that's where cooper cup
was really good at the combine whereas
40 yard dash was in the you know lower
quarter of all of those guys who ran
that year
yeah and it's a great point which is his
three cone drills specifically i think
it was the best of any receiver in the
draft that year um showing you that
ability to be full speed and change
direction
so you have a combination of things now
dan you have those shuttle drills which
will show you some of the change of
direction stuff you have the gps numbers
for actual game speed that most these
teams can access so you can see how fast
he's in the game like a great example
treylin burks uh yesterday i think we
had him four five five from from
arkansas well he's faster than he's
faster than the secondary alabama
because i saw it with my own eyes they
couldn't catch him uh when he got out
there in the open field but as such a
big guy he's not gonna he's not gonna
blow you away right off the line but
he's one of those build speed players so
i i think you got to put all that stuff
into the the proper context one thing
one thing it can do is it can alert you
to the fact that maybe a guy's had a
body change and so he's running faster
you know in the 40 than maybe you saw
him on on tape maybe he's come back from
an injury that you didn't know that he
had um so it can kind of it can kind of
alert you to some things if a guy runs
faster or slower than you anticipate um
i think it can lead you to maybe some
some good questions but a guy like
cooper cup it's a great lesson for
everybody which is i don't know he runs
away from people on tape his shuttle
drills are off the charts let's not
overthink this thing he's daniel
jeremiah you can follow him on twitter
at move the sticks nfl network's live
coverage of the combine on field
workouts continues today at four eastern
running backs offensive line special
teams where is the drama in this year's
draft
i i think it's what what uh what order
these edge rushers come off the board
dan i think we're going to see a ton of
them
we might see seven or eight of them go
in the first round i wouldn't be shocked
if we saw a handful of them go in the
top 10 picks
so to me it's kind of how they're going
to stack up we'll see them work out
gosh tomorrow we'll get a chance to see
those guys it's as good of an edge
rusher draft as i can remember
not just in kind of having some some
real top-end guys but just a sheer
number of them so when you look around
the league and you look at you know look
at the team that just won the super bowl
and you look at the teams that are
consistently good every year they've got
great quarterbacks and they've got a
great pass rush so while the quarterback
group might be down a little bit
i think this is as good a pass rush
group as we've had in a long time so
that to me is the exciting part to see
how these guys kind of sort themselves
out but i also wonder with the success
of aaron donald are we looking for the
next aaron donald it feels like we got a
lot of edge rushers
there's only one aaron donald
yeah and that's the problem is that you
you know you get an eric donald once
every 28.
you can keep you can keep looking for
them but you know i don't know if you're
if you're ever going to find one quite
like that you know chris jones and we've
got some other good ones that have had
big time impacts
we've got a solid group of defensive
tackles in this
in this draft what we do have though dan
is we've got guys that can that can be
versatile and you can let them rush
inside i think let's go back in the time
machine to
that super bowl that the giants won
against the patriots where you saw
justin tuck who was a a big defensive
end who went inside and just destroyed
those guards we've got guys like travon
walker
who's going to be 275 pounds from
georgia who can he can slide inside
there and do things like that jermaine
johnson from florida state can do that
as well i think a lot of teams call that
their nascar package you put four
defensive ends out there and let two of
those guys rush inside and beat up on
these unathletic guards i think that's
what this draft has a chance to give you
if you're kenny pickett do you walk
around indianapolis with your hands in
your pocket
[Laughter]
i don't know but i i found myself and
i've told you i don't even i don't see
it as a major deal i'm okay with his
hand size but like even on the coverage
last night when we would show him on the
screen and if there's that uh you know
that lower third graphic would be
covering up his hands and i'd be trying
to look around it like i gotta see what
his hands look
uh he got the meme treatment yesterday
though of oh said dan my phone i've got
a lot of text messages a lot a lot of a
lot of pictures a lot of pictures
i i'm gonna make you the gm of the colts
what do you do with carson wentz
oh man
um
i think i'm trying to trade him
they've made it so that i don't believe
in his contract he has any offsets at
all so if you cut him and he signs
somewhere else you're not going to get
any release or any relief i should say
from that contract which is good for him
he's going to be able to double dip if
he does get does get cut i just think
when when the owner of the organization
comes out and basically states they
don't have much confidence and they need
to get better
i don't know how that's how you run that
back so
the challenge is going to be who the
heck is there who the heck is their
quarterback
you know that that that is going to be
the challenge for them trying to figure
out who that is i
i think it's a it's one of the easier
quarterback positions to play in the
league right now with their offensive
line and run game and uh in a pretty
good defense i don't think as much as
going to be asked of that quarterback
so you know i i could see yeah i would
be shocked at all if that was like a you
know you bring in a a mariota or a
trubisky or somebody like that on a
pretty friendly deal and just see if
they can put that offense on autopilot
how about you're the gm of the eagles
what are you doing at quarterback
i'm gonna run it back with with jalen
hurts i mean i'm gonna call i'm gonna
call the the seahawks and see if there's
any way at all they'll change their mind
pull something off there i don't think
they're gonna answer i don't think
they're gonna do anything
but after you do your due diligence on
that you know you can call on aaron
rodgers i don't think that's happening
either but i think when you stack up
jalen uh with the quarterbacks in this
draft class i think i would use those
three picks
to try and add some some more players
you know seattle though daniel and i got
jalen hurts and i got three first-round
draft picks
seattle would be crazy not to take that
i would i would be making that phone
call but i mean i'm just kind of taking
peter's word the other day saying that
that's not happening no he said they
have no intention daniel you know what
that means we had no intention but then
we were blown away by this trade we
couldn't turn it down
well we can make that i've been out we
can make that trade right now i think i
would i think i would do that if i was
to philadelphia eagles you said you
would do it if the seattle seahawks so
if you can make this trade maybe they
can make it too well i think that i mean
if i'm seattle i got to get on a rookie
contract here with a quarterback i got
to be able to rebuild i get you know i
get first round draft picks i got a
chance russ is going to
you know he's 33 he's going to cost you
uh at what point do you get something in
return for him philadelphia not exactly
ready to win now maybe close but
i would do that if i'm seattle i i think
seattle is going to move i think seattle
wants to move on i just think they're
trying to figure out what exactly can
they get for russ
well i think that i think the photo of
eagles would be highly motivated they're
gonna and i actually
i actually think they're they're a team
that could make a
you know tampa bay buccaneer type leap
with somebody like russell wilson
because they're good on the line of
scrimmage they have one of the better
offensive lines in the nfl you've got
goddard who's one of the better tight
ends i think devonta smith with a guy
like russell wilson would catch a
zillion balls
defensively i know their sack numbers
were down but they've got a premier
corner and slay they've still got some
talent along that defensive line i need
to add some pieces here there but uh
yeah i could make a strong case
especially in a division that's pretty
average
the eagles could take a real quick leap
all right real quick you're the gm of
the giants
well first of all
thanks for giving me all these gm jobs
this has been a heck of a morning i've
already got four gm jobs i haven't had
lunch yet um if i'm the gm of the giants
i'm probably trying to i'm probably very
aggressively trying to trade down in
this draft i think they've got a lot of
holes to fill i think they are going to
stay committed to to daniel jones and
i'd agree with that when you stack him
up with this year's quarterbacks
to try and give him some help i don't
know if they'll find any trade partners
to slide down and collect a bunch of
picks but
that would be the effort i would be
trying to make and you got to get a good
evaluation on your quarterback this year
so they've got to upgrade the offensive
line and i think they've got to give
them another another weapon to play with
if at the end of this year
you can make a proper determination on
daniel jones i think you'd do that as a
success but they can't go into next
offseason with you know the lack of
clarity that they have right now
all right real quickly the college
quarterback we are not talking about now
but we should be or will be
yeah i think i'll give that to desmond
ritter you know i thought you saw that
yesterday his accuracy was the question
when you watched him on tape this kid's
smart he's a great leader gosh he ran
four fives yesterdays he's tremendously
athletic i think you've got a lot to
work with uh with a kid like that and i
thought he cleaned up some of the
footwork stuff that impacted his
accuracy so that's what i think we'll be
talking more about as we go forward
thank you bud have a great day we
appreciate your time as always
thanks dan appreciate you daniel
jeremiah nfl network analyst and former
nfl scout also the radio color analyst
for the chargers